salut je viens de rentrer de vacances je
suis donc de retour pour vous faire des
vidéos pendant mes deux semaines dans le
sud
j'ai remarqué qu'à pas mal de phrases
qui te font bien chier quand en vacances
la première phrase sont en vacances
c'est celle que tu reçois dans la
majorité des textos que tu envoies
généralement des proches ou des amis
fidèles à la fin ces sms les gens
adorent placer le petit truc profite
bien
à l'heure actuelle je comprends toujours
pas à quoi ça sert est ce que vous
voulez lui rappeler qu'il en vacances et
qu'il faut qu'il en profite pensez que
ça a provoqué une révélation chez lui
que du coup s'est pas construite
meilleur ou je sais pas trop quoi
[Musique]
non arrêté le mec quand il évoque
profite bien ça ne change absolument
rien à ses vacances cette phrase ne sert
à rien il faut arrêter la deuxième
fraction des vacances c'est celle que tu
chantes en tout temps dès que tu vas la
mer à la piscine ou dans une flaque
d'eau pour pour pour les petits poissons
nous que là tu mets un pied dans l'eau
pour savoir si elle est chaude ou froide
et si tu vas dedans et que ton pote qui
est déjà dedans a le malheur de dire ce
qu'elle est bonne l'autre cette fameuse
piscine à tamalé caraman glace et
l'autre sept piscines monde mais
t'inquiète une fois que boire et manger
par on dirait que même si l'eau était à
-10° le mec qui faisait rentrer dans te
dirai ça pour ça pète et c'est
insupportable cette phrase voilà voilà
alors juste ici c'est la piscine en
panne actuellement nous cas pas de
chauffage vous déconseille fortement
d'aller dedans non mais franchement
quand elles vont les bonnes c'est pas ça
fait guerrier
ça fait brut ça fait mal très viril de
lire ça je ne sais pas je comprends pas
je sais pas vous mais moi force
d'entendre cette phrase fut de
complètement parano et depuis j'ai
l'impression que les mecs qui peuvent
être partout à tout moment pour dire
cette [ __ ] de phrases là
[Musique]
non mais une fois que tu es dont il est
témoin on connaît tous ou alors on a
tout ce que nous quelqu'un qui insiste
vraiment sûr fait que la crème solaire
c'est important et ben voilà nous là
pour la première phrase super chomedey
vacances met de la crème solaire
incroyable alors ces gens là je les
comprends pas c'est à dire autant
parfois c'est vrai que des gens se
laissent vraiment aller au soleil ils
veulent bronzer à tout prix et ça en
devient carrément flippant à lucas
oublie pas de la crème solaire
autant des fois contre toi même tu sais
de protéger du soleil et ans mais déjà
c'est super loin d'avoir toutes les 20
minutes
quelque 1,4 pas te dire un dû car on met
un petit peu de crème solaire là on sait
jamais ah je te parle on met de la crème
très cher ça fait 10 fois que j'en mets
là tu trouves pas que c'est assez bas
non la preuve on regarde tu voudrais pas
un coup de soleil coin de la bouche ça
ah non non mais ça c'est le ketchup du
grec on a mangé une des leurs la
quatrième phrase super chanteur
maintenant c'est une question qui à peu
près tous les gens tu va croiser lors de
tes vacances vont poser vos parts et
quand vous en voilà une [ __ ] de
questions à double tranchant basse-côte
encore on annonce quelques jours après
son arrivée ça va c'est plutôt cool est
bon très con
par contre l'annoncé en fin de vacances
ça fait chier fait vraiment chier quand
même et vous rentrez quant au pardon
dont deux jours c'est très difficile
psychologiquement
non mais charmant tu m'avais promis est
simple s'il te plaît vraiment l'air très
triste enfin la cinquième phrase quand
on part en vacances elle est exclusive
au club comme la mède touristes rights
here are bref le truc où il ya des
animateurs qui font des animations le
soir c'est justement que les animations
ne t'intéresse pas et qu'un l'animateur
vient te voir pour faire la propagande
de sa petite animation du soir alors
autant quand les gens sont intéressés
c'est super cool mais quand on travaille
ça tous les soirs alors que ça
t'intéresse vraiment pas devient très
vite chiant alors autant le premier soir
tu dénonces gentiment salut les gars
vous êtes au courant l'animation de ce
soir vous venez ou pas ouais on est au
courant mais non c'est bon c'est bon on
fait d'avancer toujours qu'alain
prononcées vont raison des deux voies la
partie scénique est pour ça que je suis
là voilà
mais merci merci beaucoup autant au bout
d'un moment tu fais preuve de fourberie
1 pour éviter cette fameuse question là
d'horreur lemay salut les gars alors ce
soir vous êtes décidé à enfin venir un
spectacle quoi et comment elle s'appelle
l'animatrice la bonne à laquelle l'ata
et louise là je crois c'est alexandra et
incite à isabelle donc tu parles
les mecs les mac les gars vous êtes tous
et au et moi avons bien entendu c'est
que cinq phrases chiante on ne s'empêche
pas non plus de passer de bonnes
vacances évidemment ma page facebook
ayant été inquiet je vous invite à la
clé la nouvelle le lien dans la
description au huitième chrono sur
twitter et en attendant je vous dis tout
le monde puisse à bientôt aux bonnes
vacances devant l'ordi au soleil pour
ceux qui sont le soleil et une vacance
lucas profite bien
ça marche pas je déballerai fait quelque
chose pour élever une famille c'est plus
possible
oh
[Applaudissements]
par contre l'un des reculs